there's a new Guardian as a galaxy vol 2
teaser if you're like us you've already
watched it a bunch of times here's seven
things we got from me star-lord has a
new costume it's a little bulky maybe
it's a call back to his sweet old
costume from the comics well I guess it
wasn't that sweet Gamora has a sword
back the retractable sword is known as
the Godslayer it looked like she lost it
when fighting nebula in the first movie
maybe she retrieved it from the planets
lost power yondu his back I guess he's
not mad that star Lord gave him a troll
doll instead of the Infinity stone you
can also see his Mohawk is taller nebula
obviously survived her fall when
escaping from Gomorrah someone has her
in custody looks like the Milano has
crashed the Guardians have packed her
bags and are moving on star-lord still
want to hook up with gomorrah get it yes
I am a dancer Corey you just need to
find a woman who is pathetic like you
thanks boy baby Groot is so cute in his
red leather jacket for more news on
comics TV and film keep it tuned to
gamespot universe